herr Schulz vielleicht die erste Frage
an Sie die alten nicht Alpen ne mag ich
sehr aber alten Republik wie der
demografische Wandel unsere Zukunft
gefährdet so heißt ihr Buch äh und die
Frage gefährdet dieser demografische
Wandel unsere Zukunft ja altenrepublik
ist ein Wortspiel die altenreublik
irgendwer geht den Berg hoch irgendwer
muss den Berg runter und wir wissen
nicht genau wohin die Wege führen man
könnte natürlich noch begrifflich etwas
amüsanter spielen sie haben ja auch
schon gelacht bei der anmodat der Zahlen
die eigentlich sonst so erschreckend
sind ich spiel ja noch im Buch am Anfang
mit der opaollypse oder Oma gedon also
solche Sachen aber es ist ja doch ein
ernstes Thema also 18 Millionen Menschen
die in 13 Jahren in Rente gehen das sind
die Boom 18 Millionen bis bis 2000 die
ja ne die Jahrgänge 58 bis 71 also ab
2023 die nächsten 13 jahreen B 2035 in
dieser Zeit nur 11 Millionen volljährige
neue volljährige das heißt eine Lücke
von 7 Millionen auf 13 Jahre das heißt
da sind wir schon bei einer halben
Million pro Jahr die wir als
volkswirtschaftliches Defizit im
Zauberwort Erwerbspersonen Potenzial
verbuchen müssen denn das erste große
Problem ist die alten haben einen
Rentenanspruch aber wir haben kein Geld
das irgendwo rumliegt um diesem Anspruch
zu genügen sondern wir haben ein
Umlagesystem manchmal ist es nur eine
Woche zwischen wir zahlen ein die
Rentner kriegen raus das ist das wusste
ich nicht habe ich durch Ihr Buch
gelernt das läuft wirklich so ja also
wir verdienen im Januar und im Februar
hat der Rentner auf dem Konto ja im
Januar zahlen wir ein im Februar kriegt
es der Rentner wenn es so läuft wie es
gerade läuft manchmal sind es vier
Monate manchmal muss der Bundestag auch
abends noch mal Tagen weil so zwei Tage
dann doch zu knapp ist und dann sagt man
noch mal gesetzlich sind müssen aber
zwei Wochen sein aber kleines Polster
gibt es aber im Prinzip haben Sie Recht
ein miniolster es gibt jedenfalls kein
Geldspeicher die Rente liegt nicht
irgendwo man hat nur ein Rentenanspruch
er muss erwirtschaftet werden wenn wir
jedes Jahr so viel weniger neue
Erwerbstätige haben ist die Frage wo
kommt die volkswirtschaftliche Kraft her
um diese Renten zu erwirtschaften und
das ist erstmal nur die Rente dann haben
wir das Problem in der Politik wir haben
demnächst Bundesländer in denen gibt's
mehr Wähler mit Pflegestufe als Wähler
unter 30 böser Satz manche Bundesländer
haben demnächst mehr Menschen mit
Pflegegrad als Wähler unter 30 also
Mecklenburg vorpomn wä das aber wir
wissen die anderen Bundesländer
Brandenburg jetzt die uns nächstes Jahr
besonders beschäftigen Sachsen Thüring
sachsenanhal die betrifft das nicht
weniger also wir haben es grundsätzlich
mit Schieflagen zu tun bei der wir uns
so grob mal fragen müssen nicht nur
ökonomisch sondern setzt auch die
Demografie die Demokratie schachmat weil
wenn wir nach harten mathematischen
Gesichtspunkten Wahlergebnisse auszählen
und W haben aber dreimal mehr über
60-Jährige Wähler als Wähler unter 30
dann ist da einfach eine skiflager dann
muss sich jeder Wahlkämpfer überlegen
macht's noch Sinn überhaupt junge Themen
anzusprechen oder bespielen wir nur noch
die alten deren Enkel schon nicht mehr
in der Schule sind z.B weshalb W das
Bildungssystem so lahmt wie auch immer
da geht die Themenliste dann los geht ja
ich ich schau ger zu Vanessa W die nicht
mit allem einverstanden ist und die ich
aber gerne fragen würde das ist ja ein
ein letztenendes auch ein globaler Trend
in der westlichen Welt sozusagen mit ein
paar wenigen Ausnahmen ich habe vor
einiger Zeit eine interessante Zahl
gelesen oder zwei Zahlen gelesen wir
haben mittlerweile mehr Menschen über 65
als unter 5 ja das heißt wir altern
global oder was heißt das wir altern
nicht global aber wir altern im globalen
Norden ich glaube das könnte man so
sagen dass in den Industriestaaten wiger
Kinder geboren werden aber wir haben
auch durchaus andere Staaten wo noch
sehr viele Kinder geboren werden wo
viele wenn man das so sagen möchte
Arbeitskräfte z. geboren werden oder
anders formuliert junge Menschen mit
Ideen mit Tatendrang mit Arbeitswillen
Kraft Lebenszeit die sie irgendwie noch
auf in ihre Lebenszeit auf dieser Welt
verwerten wollen wo kommen die auf die
Welt wo sind die
ganz viel im asiatischen Raum also Asien
ist ein sehr junger Kontinent Indien
Südasien Z wirklich also ich ich höre
immer von genau
also ich sag mal südkorea hat ein
riesiges demografisches Problem oder
nicht die geringste
Fertilitätsrate südkorea hat die
geringste
Fertilitätsrate wo ist die wo liegt die
ich glaube die ist bei 1,2 oder so na
also zwei Kind als zwei Eltern in Japan
kriegen nicht mal ein Kind statistisch
Zustande derzeit also wir haben es mit
Hong Kong z.B eine der wirtschaftlich
stärksten Regionen der Welt wo wir auch
unter diesem Wert von ein liegen wir
sagen stagnationsswert ist 2,1 also zwei
Eltern kriegen zwei Kinder muss man
einmal kurz erklären ne um sozusagen
einfach nur an an ein Land sozusagen in
seiner Bevölkerungsstärke daz halten wo
wo es gerade ist müssen im Schnitt 2,1
Kinder 2,1 genau die 0,1 ist dann die
statistische Größe die kann man
ignorieren aber zwei Eltern zwei Kinder
wir in Deutschland liegen bei 1,4 in
Japan liegt man da drunter Südkorea ganz
weit drunter aber wir haben den
afrikanischen Kontinent also das machen
wir gleich aber Südostasien also weil
weil es immer heißt da kommen die Leute
dann her die oder überhaupt
Asien ich höre das immer anders ich k
mal mit die also Philippinen ist
vielleicht eine Ausnahme weiß ich nicht
Philippinen Indien also wir
haben in Südasien aber es ist nicht so
dass es einige wenige Länder sind wo es
mehr Kinder gibt also wir sind weltweit
nicht eine allzu alte Gesellschaft es
gibt noch diese Gesellschaften wo auch
noch viele Kinder geboren werden und das
ist spannend hinzugucken weil was sind
denn diese Menschen die sind ja nicht
Pakistan ist auch so ein Land das ist
sogar ziemlich drastisch das sorgt für
auch sehr viel migrations und sehr viele
Probleme äh auch im Land ähm wie wie
hoch ist da die die fertilitäts oder
Reproduktionsrate um es mal so zu sagen
habe ich gerade nicht im Kopf muss ich
zugeben ähm aber wir haben dort auch
eine sehr eine viel zu junge Bevölkerung
eigentlich und nicht die Möglichkeiten
diese junge Bevölkerung irgendwie zu
absorbieren oder in einem Arbeitsmarkt
zu bekommenm ähm und alle diese Menschen
gibt es jetzt die wollen sich auch
bewegen wir haben eine Welt in Bewegung
wie nie zuvor
ähm also muss auch sagen wir stagnieren
also wir sind auch auf einem niedri W
ich so zwischen 2 3% der Menschen sind
Migranten auf der Welt aber es gibt
Menschen die bewegen sich und jetzt ist
die Frage wo wo gehen die hin wo wollen
sie hingehen wo sehen sie ihre Zukunft
wo wollen Sie sich einbringen und da
finde ich die Analyse des
indisch-amerikanischen Beraters und
geographieexerten
sehr spannend der sagt die Wellen mit
ihren Füßen und wohin diese Migranten
oder die jungen Menschen von heute gehen
ist ein sehr interessanter Indikator
dafür welche anderen Länder profitieren
oder wie sie sich auch in Zukunft
weiterentwick könten also wer ist
attraktiv für junge Menschen die etwas
tun wollen sie sagen da gibt's ein
Wettbewerb quasi es gibt einen wettbew
also wir müssen uns anstrengen wenn wir
die die die die cleveren die die voller
Taten dragen wenn wir die haben wollen
ja ist kein Selbstläufer und es ist auch
schon heute so also wenn man mal
rumfragt auch Leute die durchaus
ausgebildet sind die ein Studium
vielleicht hinter sich haben wo wollt
ihr denn hin dann ist Deutschland nicht
unbedingt mehr die erste Antwort sondern
viele Menschen sagen Deutschland mussut
lern es ist schwer schwierig in die
Bürokratie irgendwie reinzufinden und
vielleicht dann doch eher Kanada USA
Australien also es ist auch nicht so wir
sprechen hier in Deutschland oft so als
als müssen wir alle erstmal abwehren als
hätten wir so ein ganz großes Problem
aber eigentlich sind wir auch gar nicht
mehr ganz vorne dran was es betrifft die
Leute zu uns zu bringen so attraktiv zu
scheinen also vielleicht noch einmal es
ist wirklich ein wie man so sagt
sekularer Trend den man überall sieht in
allen reichen
Industrienationen geht die Geburtenrate
zurück was erstmal ja ein bisschen
überraschend ist weil intuitiv könnte
man ja denken wenn es den Menschen
besser geht dann sind sie optimistischer
und das geben Sie auch den Nachkommen
weiterr Geld kannh kindau aber es ist
gerade zuu umgekehrt arme Menschen haben
mehr Kinder also Afrika hat tatsächlich
eine sehr hohe Reproduktionsrate aber es
scheint stärker zu sein dass wenn die
Menschen reicher werden dann werden sie
auch individualistischer sagen es gibt
andere Präferenzen im Leben
und sie verfolgen die mehr als eine
große oder zumindest eine eine normale
Familie mit eins oder zwei Kindern zu
haben die einzige Ausnahme
interessanterweise unter den reichen
Ländern ist Israel und das sind nicht
nur die Ultraorthodoxen Gemeinden
sondern es insgesamt die sind glaube ich
bei 2,9 weil man do dort hohen
Kindersegen mit gottwohlgefälligkeit
gleichszt da spielt die Religion dann
offenkundig doch noch eine große Rolle
ich w auch bei den bei denen die
Religion wenig Rolle spielt ich kenne
das da ein bisschen man liebt Kinder man
hat Kinder das ist so ein wie soll man
sagen es gehört dazu genau das klingt
jetzt ein bisschen platt aber ich glaube
so ist es mehr oder weniger ich würde
aber gern vielleicht noch ein bisschen
den Akzent verändern weil W W wo ist es
denn am schlechtesten in den sogenannten
reichen Ländern tatsächlich Südkorea
Südkorea liegt es daran erzählt mir auch
eine eine Freundin die dort und Kollegin
die dort von den Economist arbeitet dort
ist es wohl so äh dass die Frauen sehr
gut ausgebildet sind und Sie wissen aber
wenn sie heiraten und Kinder kriegen
dann werden sie in das konventionelle
Familienmodell der asiatischen
Gesellschaft von früher integriert und
insofern ist genau ist der Umkehrschluss
äh doch scheint so zu sein ist der
Umkehrschluss dann Blei ich lieber
kinderlos und bekomme und und und lebe
ein Leben mit einer Karriere mit hohem
Einkommen und hoher
Selbständigkeit das Paradox warum so
viel Handlungsmöglichkeit und Freiraum
durch gute Bildungssysteme gute
Möglichkeiten und so weiter zu weniger
Kindern führt ist gar nicht so
kompliziert ich glaube wir können es
alle selber fühlen vor allem wenn wir
jetzt jünger sind weil wir relativ viele
Chancen nutzen können aber dann auch
dazu verurteilt werden sich nutzen zu
müssen denn die Miete muss irgendwie
bezahlt werden der Bildungskredit muss
bezahlt werden und und damit rutscht
dieser Kinderwunsch ganz weit nach
hinten man muss erstmal das Wohnen
klären das ist aufwendig genug da müssen
sich schon zwei finden und eine echte
Schicksalsgemeinschaft Gründen denn wir
kennen ja die Werte wie es in Frankfurt
Hamburg und den Metropolen so aussieht
dann ist die Frage wenn es mit dem
Wohnen klappt klappt's auch mit dem
Arbeiten klappt's mit dem arbeiten so
dass man auch eine langfristige
Perspektive hat so dass man sich dann
den Kinderwunsch sousagen wieder
freiarbeitet der Kinderwunsch wird also
aus ökonomischen Gründen relativ weit
nach hinten geschoben und dieses Problem
aber dann kommen sie ja die Kinder also
das kann ja nicht sein wenn wir immer
reicher werden wenn un es immer besser
geht dann kann doch jetzt nicht
umgekehrt wie sie argumentieren die
Tatsache dass wir weniger Geld zur
Verfügung haben der Grund hab wir werden
natürlich Reich ja aber es geht uns noch
nie ist es uns so gut gegangen wie zur
Zeit kogntiv in den
Zahlen Kollektiv werden wir reicher das
stimmt aber das heißt doch alle werden
reicher natürlich in span natürlich
Spanne aber alle werden reicher ja also
wenn man in sagen wir mal man ist ein
Ärzteehepaar und damit in Frankfurt sehr
reich dann sucht man sich ein Haus und
möchte aber zwei Kinderzimmer haben
perspektivisch das heißt 50% des
monatlich verfügbaren Einkommens ist
erst mal weg wenn sie allein erziehend
sind also eine trennungsgeschichte für
die sie gar nichts können und Sie haben
schon zwei Kinder überweisen Sie am dr
eines Monats 100% ihres Nettovermögens
an den Vermieter da ist dann die Frage
wie kommt da noch ein Kinderwunsch
zustande wir schieben ihn weit auf was
dann auch wieder bedeutet umso weiter
wir ihn aufschieben umso weniger ist ein
Platz noch für das dritte Kind damit
werden wir eingefangen beim zweiten Kind
und wenn auf dem Arbeitsmarkt alle im
gleichen Alter konkurrieren mit ich kann
übrigens etwas flexibler arbeiten ich
habe keine Kinder dann vererbt sich oder
besser es infizieren sich auch die
anderen mit diesem kinderlosen leben
obwohl das nicht dem eigenen Wunsch
entspricht also man hat ein Kinderwunsch
auch in Deutschland der Kinderwunsch ist
höher als wir tatsächlich wir sind z
Mittelfeld sind wir Herr Hand
widerspricht ich kann das einfach nicht
teilen zu zumal wenn es so wäre seit 20
Jahren ist die Politik dabei
äh die Kinder zu fördern mit allen
Möglichkeiten Kindergeld
Kinderfreibetrag
Erziehungszeiten also es wird die
Ausgaben die wir auch staatlich aus
Steuermitteln und und und und aus
Krediten für die Kinder ausgeben die
sind gestiegen innerhalb von 30 Jahren
nicht so Steig wie die
Wohnkosten die Wohnkosten sind in den
Städten natürlich gestiegen weil dort
alle Leute hin wollen aber trotzdem aber
trotzdem aber das ist doch kein Grund
keine Kinder zu kriegen das ist niemand
also das können sie wirklich das eine
steile These aber es können Sie wirklich
nicht ernsthaft sagen dass wir prate
anschauungche Anschauung ist leider
keine Statistik ja aber ich kenne ja
meine
schisalsgemeinschaft ja aber ich kann es
auch bestätigen ich meine ich bin ja
jetzt eine dieser jungen Frauen und
es sind einfach andere Verhältnisse als
damals man tut nicht mal die ganze große
Familie in ein Zimmer und das ist schon
etwas was man viel so hört ob man sich
das zutraut okay okay okay aber dann
müssen wir jetzt mal das was sie da
gerade sozusagen so nebenbei mitliefern
ist unsere Ansprüche sind deutlich höher
geworden ja interessant kommt natürlich
aus einer etwas anderen Generation und
argumentiert auch anders ich sag mal
unsere Eltern haben ehrlich gesagt mit
sehr viel Gottvertrauen Kinder bekommen
die hatten Horror Inflation zu 13 12 12
13 14 % in Italien der damaligen Zeit
und meine Eltern haben drei Kinder
bekommen die hatten keinen Plan davon
wie das eigentlich gehen soll aber sie
haben darauf vertraut dass es irgendwie
funktioniert und das würde ich schon
sagen dass uns dieses Vertrauen darauf
dass man schon irgendwie hinkriegt das
ist unser Pen gekommen wir wollen es
perfekter machen wir wollen es besser
machen wir wollen wissen wie wir die
Kinder ausbilden können und wenn wir das
nicht ganz sicher wissen dann sagen wir
lieber al dann lass mal in unserem Haus
Frankfurt wo sie sagen da kann man
überhaupt keine Kinder mehr kriegen
wohnten als wir da eingezogen sind unten
130 quadr äh eine Familie zwei Kindern
und die Großeltern wohnten da auch noch
jetzt sind über uns die Familie
ähnlicher grundkrist normaler nix Luxus
Altbau 130 m² ein paar beide berufstätig
mit zwei Kindern ausgezogen weil sie
gesagt haben das können wir der Familie
nicht mehr zumuten auf so beengt Raum zu
reden so so ist es also die Ansprüche
sind wirklich größer geworden das ist ja
in Ordnung aber dann muss man bereit
sein und man kann es ja doch auch dann
muss man bereit sein mehr Geld eben auch
für das Wohnen auszugeben jedenfalls
wenn man es da wo alle hin wollen wo
gerade die jungen Familien alle auch hin
wollen nämlich in den Ballungsgebieten
in Frankfurt in München in Hamburg und
in Stuttgart zu zu wohnen Herr Winkel
rutscht schon die ganze Zeit sehr nervös
bei einer dieser sehr jungen Menschen
heute hier in der Runde wie alt sind sie
ja Winkel wenn ich fragen darf 32 ach
guck also praktisch kurz vor
Pubertät vor oder nach sie sie wollten
gerade was geht Ihnen durch den Kopf
wenn sie das Hören und wie schwer ist es
auch Politik zu machen unter diesen
Umständen weil da verändern sich ja ein
paar sehr entscheidende Parameter ich
bin mal auf den Punkt von her Schulz
eingehen der das am Anfang beschrieben
hat und bei der Beschreibung des
demografischen Wandels muss man sich ja
erstmal klar machen das ist ja keine
politische Meinung sondern das ist ja
einfach Mathematik also dass der
demografische Wandel über uns h
reinbricht das ist jetzt keine
überraschende t Sache sondern schlicht
und ergreifend an den Geburtenzahlen
ablesbar so was wir glaube ich als
Politik für ein Problem haben ist wir
hatten ursprünglich mal ein
Generationenvertrag der sah so aus dass
die jungen Beitragszahler die alten
Rentner
finanzieren zeigen nehme ich i
persönlich übel aber das das das war das
war ich habe nicht auf sie gezeigt
sondern
generell und das Problem ist dass dann
irgendwann mal die Politik diesen
generationvertrag einseitig zu Lasten
der jungen Generation aufgekündigt hat
die Politik hat irgendwann gesehen die
Demografie in unserem Land kippt weg und
hat dann aber keine wirklichen Maßnahmen
getroffen und hat gesagt na ja wir
könnten man hätte ja auch sagen können
wir versuchen die Familienpolitik mal
früher anzugehen systematischer
anzugehen und das Problem war aber dass
man stattdessen gesagt hat na ja am Ende
des Tages was die steigende rentenzahl
anbelangt die das Geld holen wir uns
einfach aus dem allgemeinen Steuertopf
der dafür überhaupt Null vorgesehen war
also Sie haben es ja am Anfang gesagt in
der Einleitung über 100 Milliarden Euro
in die GL mitler 112 glaube ich genau
glau B der Bundeshaushalt ist irgendwo
bei knapp ein halben Billion 470
Milliarden und davon der mit Abstand
größte Posten da siehst du es genau der
mit Abstand größte der mit Abstand
größte Posten von diesem
gesamtbundeshaushalt geht in die Rente
nur der Ursprungsgedanke des
generationvertrags also das Umlagesystem
war ja dass gar kein einziger Euro aus
dem Bundeshaushalt in die Rente geht
sondern dass dieser Bundeshaushalt für
die junge Generation also auch für
Investition in die Zukunft zur Verfügung
steht und das ist
leider das unsere Investition in die
Zukunft ist die wir da hinten sehen das
das ist leider einseitig von der Politik
aufgehoben worden natürlich dann noch
mit mit so Sachen wie Rente mit 6 kom
vielleicht später noch mal drauf zu
sprechen also wirklich Sachen wo man
sich sagen muss D das ist wirklich
Jenseits jenseits jeder Rationalität wo
er mittlerweile selbst Andrea nales sagt
das war das war ein Fehler sagt sie das
und Olaf Scholz auch nee sagt sie nicht
sie hat glaub
ich ja aber nur bestimten Kontext so
richtig sagt sie das nicht deswen dann
übernehme ich einfach für sie mit so
heute hab ich mal die Chance sie können
jetzt mal ehrlich sein also wird Politik
für alte Leute gemacht ja
natürlich wie Herr schz wie Herr Schulz
wie Herr Schulz das vorhin beschrieben
hat man muss aufpassen dass das
demografische Problem nicht irgendwann
zum demokratischen Problem wird also man
hätte ja auch sagen können statt dass
wir jedes Jahr 12 Milliarden Euro für
die Rente mit 63 ausgeben geben wir die
gleiche Summe für Investition in
Digitalisierung aus
um unser Land fit für die Zukunft zu
machen und ich persönlich glaube dass
die Politik in den letzten
Jahen und zwar unabhängig von der
Parteipolitik da nehme ich meine Partei
wie jeder andere genau mit leider kein
wegan ma ich auch mache ich auch und da
hat jede
Bundesregierung ja diese
Zukunftsinvestition sag legt sich mit
mit den silvurfern mit denen legt man
sich nicht an ich zeig jetzt nicht auf
sie aber mit den mit den
silverurfernterweg genau ich bin schon
ist schon durch das Thema ja natürlich
ist es eine also offensichtlich ist ist
eine Frage für die Politik wie setz sich
die Prioritäten und ich habe das Gefühl
dass die Prioritäten jedenfalls nicht
bei der jungen Generation gelegt werden
und das ist ein riesen Problem man man
kann das den Leuten auch nicht vorwerfen
ne dass sie Teil von Geburten starken
jahrgangen sind und dass sie älter
werden und dass sie sich Herr Hang fühlt
sich angesprochen Rente verdient haben
das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung nein
es geht aber es geht aber auch nicht
darum irgendwelchen
Leuten darum le deswegen möchte ich hier
gerne sofort intervenieren denn das
klang jetzt so weil sie häufiger mein
Namen genannt haben und so weiter ich
möchte da nämlich nicht zustimmen sowohl
Herr hangsansatz jetzt so ein Appell an
die Jugend zu machen bekommt doch mal
trotzdem mehr Kinder trot perspektiv nur
festgestellt aber überhaupt kein Appell
gesagt kein Appell aber so die große
Frage warum denn nicht das sind
Präferenzen der Menschen freie
Entscheidungen sonst gar nichts freie
Entscheidung sind freie Entscheidungen
also da kann man natürlich drüber reden
aber nicht so dass man dann irgendwie
was fordert und das hat er aber nicht
gemacht hat er nicht gemacht gut aber
ich will nur sagen ist ja Gegenteil
wur die Leute sollen leben wie sie
wollen wir wollen wohlwollend über die
Jungen reden aber auch über die alten
und und über die Politik die Politik hat
irgendwann vor 35 Jahren so irgendwann
in den 80ern entschieden wir entkoppeln
jetzt Lohnentwicklung und Produktivität
seitdem hält die lohnnentwicklung nicht
mehr mit und damit auch die
Lohnnebenkosten und so weiter deswegen
lief dieses Defizit auf dass wir sagten
wir brauchen eine zweite Quelle die die
Rentenkassen stützt und wir haben uns
für den Bundeshaushalt entschieden jetzt
kann man natürlich rückblickend sagen da
haben wir ein Fehler gemacht es muss
wieder gut gemacht werden wie auch immer
hier werden die alten irgendwie falsch
bedient es ist die Lasten aller weil es
der allgemeine Steuertopf ist ich würde
sagen dann sind wir ehrlich und sagen
wir holen die Unternehmen wieder ins
Boot seit 30 Jahren reicht es nicht was
die Rentenkassen selber aus der
Produktivität der Unternehmen wo die
Menschen arbeiten die dann Rente
bekommen schöpfen dieses Geld reicht
einfach nicht also machen wir es jetzt
über den Bundeshaushalt sagen aber auch
das ist jetzt der richtige Weg nur wir
finden dann für die diesen gigantischen
Teil Bundeshaushalt eine neue
geldzugangsquelle und zwar in der
Produktivität also im Ertrag dieser
Unternehmen und die Unternehmen in
Deutschland verdienen wahnsinnig viel
Geld wir haben nicht ein Problem mit zu
wenig Geld sondern wir müssen es nur
wieder so umlenken und zwar über den
Bundeshaushalt die Entscheidung ist
jetzt getroffen das können wir nicht
wieder revidieren über den
Bundeshaushalt aber der Bundeshaushalt
braucht diese Quelle wir können nicht
alles in Verschuldung weren wir gesehen
was wir für Diskussionen führen jetzt im
November und Dezember wenn um
Verschuldung geht wenn wir das
rententhema so führen wie wir die
verschuldungsthemen diskutieren dann
führt es einfach ins Chaos also das ist
einfach Katastrophe das können wir uns
nicht leisten in Deutschland dafür ist
es zu ernst dass wir die nächsten 13
Jahre die babybomer durch die Rente
bringen müssen